ليلى يبدو ان اليوم يوم المعارك في
والمواجهه في شمال القطاع بحسب الفيديوهات
والمعلومات التي تصلنا نحللها مع اللواء
فيس دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اللواء دويري نبدا مع محمود صور جديده يوم
29 من الجاري من خان يونس وغرب خان يونس
تظهر دمارا واسعا وسواتر ترابيه صحيح
بالفعل جلال كنا نتحدث خلال الايام
الماضيه كلها عن وجود مناورات للقوات
العسكريه على الارض نتحدث عن تقدم تراجع
نتحدث عن حركه ولا نتحدث عن تمركز واليوم
صور الاقمار الصناعيه التي ظهرت الان
تتقاطع مع هذه المعلومات بشكل او باخر هنا
سنشاهد صور الاقمار الصناعيه هنا مدينه
خانيونس هنا المركز صور الاقمار الصناعيه
هي لغرب مدينه خانيونس هنا اذا ما شاهدنا
سنشاهد كميه السواتر
الترابيه قد زادت بشكل كبير جدا هنا في
المنطقه الشم الشماليه الشرقيه هذه هي هذه
النقطه هنا هي مستشفى الامل نتحدث كثيرا
عن مستشفى الامل في الاخبار ولكن اذا ما
نظرنا بشكل اقرب قليلا ايضا الى هذه
المنطقه سنشاهد بان السواتر الترابيه ايضا
كانت تتمركز
وتمتد حتى القرب من مستشفى الامل
هنا نتحدث عن حوالي 300 متر في هذه النقطه
ما بين المنطقه بيضاء واول حاجز ترابي في
هذه النقطه اقل من 300 متر وهذا قد يدل
على سرعه الحركه لكن ايضا في هذه نفس صوره
الاقمار الصناعيه في هذه النقطه سنشاهد
تدميرا كاملا لكافه المربعات السكنيه في
هذه النقطه هي
لمخيم خان يونس هنا كذلك تتمركز السواتر
الترابيه في هذا النطاق اذا تشاهدون عمليه
الضغط او قد تفسر عمليه الضغط من الشمال
الشمال الشرقي الغرب والجنوب كيف ذلك
لنتجه مره اخرى الى الخريطه التي تظهر
حركه المناورات هنا هذه الخريطه الذي التي
كنا دوما ما نتحدث عنها نشاهد هذا الخط
نشاهد الشما الغرب
والشمال لنقترب اكثر من خان
يونس بحركه المناورات هذه السواتر
الترابيه التي اظهرتها الاقمار الصناعيه
يمكننا ان نقول بان العمليات بالفعل كانت
تجري بالقرب من مستشفى الامل 300 متر
وحركه المناورات هذه رغم ان صور الاقمار
الصناعيه لم تظهر الكثير من الاليات الاها
انها اظهرت الحواجز الترابيه وبالتالي ما
قد يفسر حركه سريعه للاليات تمركز في
الشرق والتوجه باتجاه الغرب والعوده نتحدث
عن مسافات قصيره يعني الى اخر وحتى يعني
كامل القطاع ربما من الغرب الى الشرق لا
يتجاوز 14 كيلومترا بالتالي حركه
المناورات هذه وكيفيه العمل ستكون خاضعه
التحليل العسكري لكن قبل ذلك سنتجه الى
الشمال شمال قطاع غزه شمال قطاع غزه كان
مركز العمليات خلال هذا
اليوم العنوان الرئيسي للعمليات كان
الغارات الجويه الغارات الجويه
كانت في النهار تتركز على بيت حانون بيت
لاهيه جباليا اضافه الى وسط مدينه غزه ومن
اللافت ان هذه المناطق التي نراها باللون
الاصفر في الجنوب ايضا تركزت عليها
الغارات
الجويه لكن
هذه المناطق التي جرت فيها العمليات
الجويه ايضا فيها تمركز بري هذا التمركز
البري هنا في هذه النقطه ايضا كان هناك
الكثير من العمليات العسكريه لفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي قالت بانها
استهدفت مجموعه من الدبابات وظهرت فيها
الصور بالتالي هناك تساؤل عن العمليات
العسكريه وامكانيه تحقيقها اهدافها سواء
في شمال قطاع غزه في الوسط او في الجنوب
خاصه مع اننا نتحدث ان مناطق التوغل هنا
حت تحديدا من جحر الديك في هذه النقطه
كانت بدايه التوغل في المراحل الاولى
نتحدث الان عن المرحله الثالثه على الاقل
بدء في او في شمال قطاع غزه اليوم ايضا
كان هناك انسحابات للاليه
ولقوات البريه ما هذه الانسحابات دعونا
نشاهد هذه الصوره هنا كان هناك توزع ل
الالويه نتحدث عن سابقا ثلاث كتائب في
الشمال ثلاث ك عفوا ثلاثه الويه في الشمال
ثلاثه الويه في الوسط و وخمسه الويه في
الجنوب الثقل مركز ثقل العمليات الاساسيه
هو في الجنوب لكن اليوم تم سحب هذا اللواء
لواء المشاه رقم خمسه وبالتالي سحبه من
العمليات وتخفيف العمليات في شمال قطاع
غزه بالتالي يصبح مجموع الالويه المنسحبه
حسب معهد دراسات الحروب حوالي 11 لواء في
حين يبقى تقريبا حوالي 10 الويه عامله في
في كامل قطاع غزه من شماله وحتى جنوبه
خمسه منها في خان يونس هذا ابرز ما لدينا
جلال اليوم وربما نتجه لتحليل العسكري
معرفه كيفيه التقاطع ما بين الاقمار
الصناعيه المناورات وتوزيع الالويه
والانسحابات والمرحله الثالثه من العمليات
سنركز اكثر على الشمال ولكن انت ذكرت
مستشفى الامل محمود قبل قليل الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني قال بان قوات الاحتلال
تقتحم ساحات مستشفى الامل وتتمركز امام
قسم الاستقبال وتطلق النار بكثافه تعليق
سريع قبل الحديث عن الشمال ماذا يحقق جيش
الاحتلال من استراتيجيه اقتحام المستشفيات
يعني من وجهه نظر عسكريه لا يحقق شيء
بالمطلق هو عندما يهاجم مستشفى هل يوجد
بها مقاتلين هل يوجد بها مستودعات اسلحه
لا هو يحاول ان يقضي على كل مقومات الحياه
كما عمل في الاندونيسي وكما عمل في الشفاء
الى غير ذلك يعني هذا هذا مؤشر على تردي
البعد الاخلاقي والقيمي وال استهتار
بالقانون الدولي رغم انه رفعت
به جنوب افريقيا اتهام ارتكاب جرائم حرب
لكنه ل لم يبالي حتى هذه اللحظه اباده
جماعيه حتى ليس فقط اباده جماعيه ليس فق
اباده جماعيه نعم وبالتالي هو يعني يعتبر
نفسه فوق القانون ولكن هذا هو انحطاط
اخلاقي لانه هذا الجيش لا يعرف ال وحتى كل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي لا يعرف الا الحقد
والكره للاخرين هذا هو مكان تحديدا مستشفى
الامل في في خانيونس
وبحسب طبعا الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في
غزه بان قوات الاحتلال تحاصر الان هذه
الساحه ساحه مستشفى الامل وتتمركز مقابل
مبنى ال الاستقبال وتطلق النار بشكل كثيف
طيب نعود الى الشمال لواء دويري انت قبل
ايام قلت وا استشرفت عوده القتال بشراسه
الى مناطق الشمال شمال القطاع والى مدينه
غزه رغم بان الاحتلال قبل اسابيع قال بانه
يعني تقريبا ينهي مهامه في مناطق الشمال
لماذا تخبرك عوده المواجهه هو تاكيد لما
كنا قد تحدثنا به وتوقعنا لانه الان
اي فصار المقاومه تحديدا للقسام اعادت
تنظيم او تنظيم قواتها واعادت تاهيل اي
الالويه ويوجد لوائين كما ذكرنا سابقا
لواء غزه ولواء الشمال بواقع 12 كتيبه
وبداوا حتى ابعد من ذلك بداوا يمارسوا
بدايات السيطره المدنيه والاداره المدنيه
لهذه المنطقه وهذا ما ازعج الكيان
فبالتالي بدا ينفذ عمليات الاقتحام لكنها
تبقى عمليات محدوده الان عندما دخل الى
الشيخ عجلين ولا تل الهواء هذه هي القوات
موجوده اصلا في وادي غزه وبالتالي اصطدم
بواقع مر والفيديو اليوم اظهر ذلك تدمير
ذبابتين وتدمير جرفن فبدا يت تحول الى
عمليه القصف القصف عن بعد سواء صاروخي او
سلاح جو وبالتالي هنا تصبح المعادله مختله
ما بين المقاومه وما بين جيش الاحتلال
لانه امكانات المقاومه لا تمكنها من الحاق
الضرري به الا من خلال المسافه الصفريه
وبالتالي ستلج المقاومه الى تنشيط حركتها
فوق سطح الارض من اجل اجباره على الدخول
طيب كان لافتا اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
مقتل رائد ضابط رائد من وحدات النخبه يسقط
عدد كبير من وحدات النخبه على الارض الل
اللوا تعتبر راس الحربه هي راس هذه الوحده
شال داغ هي تتبع سلاح الجو اسمها شال داغ
شان داغ نعم تتبع سلاح الجو وتعتبر قوات
نخبه عملها الرئيسي العمل خلف خطوط العدو
هكذا في ادبيات ولها تدريبها الخاص
والتدريب المميز الان لاحظ الخسائر تتركز
في جولاني في جفعاتي في قوش داغ في قوات
النخبه لانه تعتبرها الاكثر تاهي لخوض
المعركه خاصه في المناطق المبنيه وبالتالي
هم كذلك الضباط الاسرائيليين يكونوا مع
موجات القتال الاولى فترت ترتفع بهم نسبه
الاصابات
والقتل قوات النخبه الاسرائيليه تحتاج الى
قوات نخبه من من الطرف الاخر للمواجهه ولا
ليس هذا ضروريا يعني الان الطرف الاخر لا
يوجد تنظيم واضح انما يعتبر كله قوات نخبه
تعتبر فسائر المقاومه كلها قوات نخبه لانه
شاهدنا
فيديوهات في
معظم مناطق غزه وشعرنا بان المقاتل هو
المقاتل سواء كان في الشجاعيه او في بيت
حانون او في خان يونس انا اصنفه جميعهم
ونخبه وبتالي لا تمايز يعني قدره وامكانيه
المقاتل من كتائب القسام وال الفصائل
الفلسطينيه تضاهي قدره وقوه مقاتل النخبه
من الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا ما كنت اتحدث به
في عام 2021 انه
اي المقاتل الفلسطيني صاحب الفرصه الواحده
لا الان اقول اكثر من ذلك ان المهاره
الفرديه لدى المقاتل الفلسطيني اعلى من
المقاتل من قوات النخبه من جيش الاحتلال
والفيديوهات تحدد ذلك يعني لننظر ال نقارن
بين الفيديوهات الفيديو الذي يقدمه القسام
او سرايا القدس والفيديو الذي يقدمه الجيش
الاحتلال الفيديو الاول يعكس يعطيك صوره
كامله يعطيك صوره كامله بينما الفيديو
الاخر هو يعطيك يعطيك انطباع ان هذا
الفيديو صور في منطقه بعد انتهاء المعركه
في تلك المنطقه هذا اذاا في تل الهواء نعم
لهذه المعارك ملاحظ ايضا اللواء الدويري
دائما استهداف الاليات العسكريه بالمناطق
القاتله سواء كان دي 9 او حتى الميركافا
بالمنطقه الفاصله ما بين البرجم وجسم
الدبابه هذه مهاره الرامي ان يحدد ال
النقطه القاتله او نقطه الضعف نقطه الوهن
في الهدف لانه بتكون الاصابه قاتله
والنتيجه جيده ومثمره وبالتالي نجد انه
معظم حالات التفجير يعني احن نقيس شده
الضربه من طبيعه الكره كره اللهب التي
تخرج معظمها هي انظر هي معظمها تخرج من
منطقه تكون في منطقه البرج وتفضي الى
تدمير بعض الذخائر الموجوده في داخل
الدبابه عندما تشاهد كره اللهب كما كما
وصفتها الان هل هذا يعني بان ال الاليه
العسكريه تم اعطاب او او انها تم الحاك
ضرر فيها يعني تضررت تضررت بصوره كبيره
جدا اها يعني في بعض الحالات لا يمكن
اصلاحها ولا حتى في المشاغل الخلفيه
ولاحظنا في احد الفيدات عمليات سحب لبعض
هذه الاليات وفي بعض الاليات دمرت بالكامل
عندما تن فجر الذخيره الداخليه دائما
الياسين 105 هو مفتاح يعني هو
يات هناك توام ياسين تاندم يعني توينز
تلاحظ هنا الاستهداف من من منطقه مرتفعه
مرتفعه لانه هذه مناطق مبنيه كلما ا
المنطقه المرتفعه تعطيك خط نظر بينما اذا
كانت على مستوى الارض قد تكون طيات
الارضيه او ما شابه ذلك تعيق النظر اذا
اتيح لك الفرصه ان تستهدف من مكان مرتفع
فخط النظر مفتوح وانا قلت هذه الاسلحه
ليست موجهه لا بالاشعه تحت الحمراء ولا
بالليزر ولا فاير فورجيت هذا توجيه بصري
في هذا الفيديو لاحظنا
انه الاداه المعده للتسديد وضبط
الانحرافات راكبه على البندقيه فبالتالي
هذه تشبه ما كان يركب على بندقيه ميمون
الامريكيه اللي كانت في ستينيات القرن
الماضي طبعا هذا الفيديو نراه مره اخرى
دائما بالحديث عن جبهه الشمال وهي كانت
ناشطه اليوم خلال هذه الفيديوهات هل
بالضروره
تنشيط جبهه الشمال يخفف الضغط عن جبهه
الجنوب لا الان هناك القوات مستقله الان
لكل منطقه خصص قوات فبالتالي القوات
المخصصه للشمال مستقله في اداره المعركه
عن الموجوده في الوسط عن الموجوده في
الجنوب وبالتالي لاحظ في الشمال كانت
الفرقه
162 في الوسط 99 في الجنوب الفرقه 8
وبالتالي هؤلاء قاده مسؤولين عن اداره
معركتهم كلهم في منطقته وهذا ينطبق ايضا
على الفصائل الفلسطينيه هي تقاتل في كل
جبهه على حداء اها تؤثر على ادائها بشكل
عام في في المنطقه الشماليه تم اعاده هكذا
اقرا تم اعاده رسم الخطوط
المسؤوليه خطوط الدفاع الدفاع و مسؤوليه
الدفاع وبالتالي بدات الان تجد كتب
الشجاعيه تاخذ اجزاء من التفاح او من
الدرج
لكن
كلاهما يعني حتى فقط القسام يمارس ال
مركزيه في اداره المعركه على المستويات
الدنيا بينما يمارس المركزيه في الامور
التي تتعلق باطلاق الصواريخ خاصه في عمق
فلسطين المحتله طيب لفتنا اليوم ايضا
تصريح لبنيامين نتنياهو واريد ان اقراه
لكي اكون دقيقا
ايضا بحسب القناه الثثاني عش الاسرائيليه
قالت بان نتنياهو ابلغ عائلات الرهائن انه
سيقر صفقه لا تضر بامن اسرائيل وان ادت
لانهيار حكومته يعني هو الان مستعد
للتضحيه بالحكومه مقابل اقرار صفقه لتبادل
المحتجزين بالاسرى بماذا يخبرك هذا اعتقد
انها استجابه لما ما تحدث به بنت يوم امس
عندما قال انه قد يعطيه شبكه امان يعني
وكانت شبكه الامان تفسيرها بانه سموتريش
بنفير قد يخرجوا فانا ادخل مكانهم
طيب طيب الان سنتابع فيديو من من البريج
والمغازي نتابع
الفيديو
[موسيقى]
الله
اكبر
هوايه مل هذه القدي تخبط في طاوله الكبت
شاء اتفقنا
[موسيقى]
سدد الله
اكبر
الله اكبر واكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واكبر هات تقر لعيلتي ان شاء الله ان شاء
الله تقر عيلت باذن
الله
[موسيقى]
m
بدنا هوايه مل هذ الق تخبط في طاوله الكب
اتفقنا الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
واكبر
ه طق لعيبت ان شاء الله ان شاء الله تق
اللي عذ
[موسيقى]
الله
اذا صور من كتائب القسام فيديو يعرض لاول
مره لعمليات جديده في البريج والنصيرات في
وسط قطاع غزه اللواء الدويري ايضا
لاستهداف اليات واضح من خلال القوه الراج
انظر الى هذا المنظر يعني يحمر القاذف
ويركض باتجاه هدف قد يكون دبا ناقله النمر
واو دبابه الميركافا هذه تبدو مكافه صح
هذا هذا يعلم
الناس مفهوم الشجاعه والرجوله والتضحيه
هذا هذا في خروجه الحالي هو يضع احتمال
99% قد يصاب قبل ان يستهدف الهدف ولكنه
يصر ويراهن على ال 1% وينجز المهمه و
ويطلق اصيب اصابه مباشره اذا كما تبعنا
هنا هنا لاحظنا هناك من يتحدث الى هذا
المقاتل ويقول له اطلق دائما وابدا هناك
شخص مسؤول عن الاستطلاع يعني في معظم
الحالات بيكونوا اربع اشخاص في حالات ثلاث
اشخاص في الحالات النادره بيكون شخصين
لانه هذا يكون حامل القاذف ويترس
وهناك العين التي يبصر بها هو هو الشخص
الاخر لاحظ في احد الافلام الفيديوهات
التي عرضت تحركت
جارفه قال له لا تطلق دبابه انتظر انتظر
وبالتالي اذا في يعني الان في بعض اللقطات
كانوا اربعه اللي هو حامل القاذف
وحامل الكليشن مشان اذا هناك جنود
وقائد او المسؤول عن الاستطلاع والمصور
فبيكون اربع اشخاص في معظم الحالات
وبالتالي نسمع توجيهاته
و ويحدد له الهدف هنا هنا نلاحظ بقايا هذه
تحصينات صح وهذه درع درع واقي لجندي وهذه
حماله حماله حمال نعم نعم ام هذا ايضا هذا
كانها صفائح
التقويه للاليه او المركبه هذه بعض
الملابس على ما يبدو لجنود اسرائيليين
سقطوا جرا هذه ا يعني هذا الفيديو من
بدايته ل يعني اذا اخذنا الفيديو ك حلقه
متكامله نجد في تسلسل منطقي للعمليه التي
تم تنفيذها اها بد من حركه الشخص حامل
القاذف نداء رجل الاستطلاع و اطلاق مشاهده
الهدف
واطلاق المقذوف
ومشاهده احتراق الهدف اذا هو عرض سيناريو
متكامل لعمليه ناجحه بينما الافلام اللي
بقدمها جيش الاحتلال تمثل طرف واحد من
المعادله ونرى فقط جنود الاحتلال يدقون
النار على على جهه على على المباني او يضع
الشباك يضعوا الدائره الحمراء على الشباك
المدرسه صحيح ايضا نتابع هذا الفيديو مره
جديده لنتوقف عند ابرز م جاء فيه من
استهدافات ل اليات عسكريه على ما تبدو
بانها ميركافا و وناقله جند نمر ودي 9
بحسب ايضا مفت هذه تبدو ميركافا صح هذا
برج هذا البرج نعم صحيح مسافه قريبه لواد
سيدي هو اصلا الحد الاقصى للاستهداف 100
متر 100 متر فقط الحد الاقصى للاستهداف
100 متر بعدها تصبح فاعليه المقذوف اقل
وبالتالي كافه المشاهد اللي بشاهدها حدها
الاقصى 100 متر ولكن في لحظات شاهدنا على
مسافه 10 امتار اي اعتقد انك شاهدت
الفيديو الذي اطلق من داخل المنزل وتطايرت
قطع ال الدبابه ودخلت الى الحجره التي
اطلق من الصاروخ اخيرا قبل ان اعود الى
الى ليلى يبدو بان كتائب القسام والفصائل
الفلسطينيه تجد حلولا للتحصينات التي التي
تطورها قوات الاحتلال على مدرعاته صحيح
نعم وهذا هذا الامر اوضح ما كان فيما
يتعلق بالروب روبوتات الاثنين سواء
الروبوت الذي كان يصدر اصوات وطلقات ناريه
تتماشى مع ما يصدر من الميركافا او حتى
الروبوت التايجر المسلح الذي كان يطلق
النيران وجدوا له الحلول شكرا لك اللواء
فيزو الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي